contre tsonga llodra ont été saisis et
stéphane bern
alors en fait on vous a invité parce que
je vais être beaucoup de questions que
vous avez d'ici l'été
mais aussi par un autre raison s'il
avait été si absolument pour une autre
raison c'est que vous avez dit que
laurent gerra était rigolo et
intelligent alors là évidemment comme
vous avez la fiancée de laurent gerra
devant vous effectivement vous êtes déjà
très copains alors jack lang
vous avez une forme éblouissante ouais
c'est vrai la vie ça vous avez une forme
d une forme éblouissante on peut dire
votre âge non bah oui bien sûr soixante
ans par donc pas plus a fait aujourd'hui
suivez mon regard est alors alors que ça
va chauffer quand même c'est que vous
dira plus en âge non embrasse vous avez
un secret c'est vous dit en fait nos
sports comme churchill est sûre vous ne
faites pas de sport c'est le secret de
votre fort banale un peu quelques
quelques itinéraires bis un peu le ch
qui les aura autres et voila voila mais
vous n'êtes pas ruiner la santé à faire
leur la santé à faire du jogging
sûrement pas on en meurt bon ben c'est
bien parfois c'est un truc à savoir
alors vous êtes ministre de la culture
je le fus bas quand vous dites que vous
l'êtes pas personne ne vous croit toutes
façons si vous jouez
autant dire qu'elle voulait il vient pas
les nôtres
vous êtes président de la commission des
affaires étrangères et sait pas c'est
bien comme job ce passionné de la chose
ouais alors je suis très casanier alors
jaurès à paris bourbon avant qu'un lourd
mais valéry giscard d'estaing avant lui
et c'est une autre stature
ah bon milla les voyages et déjà
beaucoup pour les cotisants aussi
est ce que vous regrettez un peu votre
pré candidature de 95
c'est à dire en avance et les histoires
anciennes oui ça va ce soit au courant
oui ça vous regrettait pas de partie des
choses qui vous ont enrichi ce n'est pas
leur nous avons traité pas davantage aux
points est un looser ça allait passer ma
pensée et il a eu raison de me donner
tort très bien alors vous êtes vert de
blois lâche termine le curriculum vitae
vous êtes maire de blois qui vous a valu
le surnom de langue de bois mais
j'espère que ce soir j'espère c'est pas
de moi c'est cette fois avec rudy redire
ce soir j'espère vous ne serez pas
langue de bois on vous accuse souvent de
courir après la modernité alors
aujourd'hui excusez pas le sentiment
d'être un petit peu quand même sur le
plan de la modernité d'être concurrencé
quand même par cohn bendit
on n'a jamais assez nombreux
oui sauf que vous n'êtes pas les mêmes
parties une partie de sa famille
d'accord est ce que c'est parce que ça
veut dire courir qu e r non j'ai pas
spécialistes et des réponses comme ça
hambourg grand large et vous lisez
lorsque j'ai lu que vous lisez les uns
ou tu sais ce que ça veut dire ça non du
tout bon non c'est queer c'est alors je
croyais et maintenant non mais c'est que
moi je peux mais attention ce qui suit
hier non non non c'est en fait la
tendance
oui non la théorie queer c'est de dire
qu'il ya plus seulement les hommes les
femmes et les homosexuels mais qu'en
fait il ya autant de chèques ski adam
vie voilà c'est fait le coup
là oui bien sûr et c'est de répondre à
cette question vraiment en toute
franchise parmi tous les successeurs
vous avez eu à la culture et je vais me
rappeler très vite il ya eu jacques
toubon
il ya eu philippe le françois léotard
françois léotard avant il ya eu tout bon
il ya eu 12 pts blazy à vis maintenant
catherine trautmann qui a été le
meilleur à votre avis il s'améliore au
fur et à mesure est ce que vous allez
être candidat du ps aux européennes
une question qui ne s'est pas posé à mon
petit cerveau encore le sexe à la
question vous savez que la décision
oui la décision va être prise le 10
février vous le savez bien donc c'est
dans quinze jours les chez les
socialistes réfléchir
oui cela prend du temps il faut bien
dire que j'ai soupesé est ce que c'est
vrai que je ne veux pas une vie sinon
pas de voeux padoue non je ne passais
pas qui le pas il a dit que françois
hollande était un bon candidat
il n'y a pas de cumul et l'autre partie
du fromage et après que le cumul c'est
ça le problème
donc vous savez pas franchement je ne
sais pas moi je trouve alors je me
permets de vous dire ça vous feriez un
excellent quand je ne sais pas mais en
tout cas françois hollande je sois là
dit il avait un très beau produit il
faut le choisir
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas victime
finalement une sorte de des mitterrand
10 à sion il ne laisse pas cherche à
faire oublier les les années n'était
évidemment il ya une vraie est prévu que
vous seriez pas au gouvernement il avait
dit on va abandonner superphénix avait
déjà cloud c'est vrai que vous avez pas
venu et mitterrand est pourtant il ya
quand même beaucoup de choses qui sont
sortis depuis quelques années je vais
pas vous les listes et parce que tout le
monde les a en tête pour vous malgré
tout et c'est le cio n'aura pas soldé
vous êtes fidèles malgré tout vous
continuez à défendre la mémoire du
président mitterrand plus que jamais et
vous avez même créé à blois un pont
françois-mitterrand rue est bon est ce
que finalement c'est pas ça votre
problème est ce que est ce que
finalement on pourrait pas parce que les
gens qui sont aujourd'hui au
gouvernement pourrait pas vous reprocher
cette fidélité alors que veulent faire
oublier ces années mitterrand je ne
pense pas que soient leurs problèmes si
vous parlez de mes amis au gouvernement
en tout cas personnellement je
changerais pas d'un iota
la finalité une personne que j'ai
respecté que je respecte et que j'ai
je la maintiens plus forte que jamais
c'est une question aussi de direct2d tic
de vie ouais pas beaucoup ce mot mais je
considère que la fidélité à quelques
idées ou à quelques personnes avec qui
on a partagé des moments heureux ou
malheureux fait la noblesse avis si on
si tout cela est cassée qu'est ce qui
reste de ta vie et dumas vous êtes
fidèle à dumas aussi à roland dumas vous
voulez absolument faire une galerie de
portraits vous vous êtes le seul
aujourd'hui qui dit enfin des rares qui
dit dumas doit pas démissionner jeu trop
long à expliquer à 16h06 il est minuit
coiffé l'heure et il nous aurait mis
minuit non mais comment soit christine
deviers-joncour après ça aurait été
sympa de savoir si vous étiez fidèles
vous a du mal ce que lui il est plus
tellement fidèle elle enfin bon c'est
pas grave vous voulez vous rend pas ce
que c'est indiqué jamais question de
fidélité en ce cas précis c'est une
question de principe par rapport à
l'idée que je me fais de la séparation
des pouvoirs
il ya des juges d'un côté et elle est
juste de l'autre
j'estime que tant qu une personne connue
ou inconnue n'a pas été mise en cause de
façon trouver certaines les doit être
considéré on a proclamé il ya deux
siècles comme innocent et ça vaut en
particulier pour les gens qu'on ne
connaît pas qui tous les jours encore
malheureusement trop souvent sont
victimes d'arbitraire multiples de
l'administration ou de ou d'abus
policiers ou ou judiciaire vous êtes
expliqué wes a pas pris ça va après une
heure et c'est clair
mais personne n'a dormi vient pas de
mauvais endroit pour s'expliquer
derrière ça aurait été bon alors on
recommence on continue sur vos idées
politiques qui nous concerne nous les
jeunes artistes
le cannabis et l'asie en général le
cannabis chez proxi zones autonomes
vous n'êtes pas au sujet de la
légalisation de dépénalisation je suis
partisan qu'on change de la lure à
genève comment je ne sais pas où je
crois qu'il n'y a aucune raison de
désigner une le cannabis comme le lan
est le seul système de 20 de drogue
qu'ils soient pénalisés à ce point
pourquoi pas l'alcool pourquoi pas la
cigarette pourquoi pas d'autres choses
voilà j'estime que je voulais sortir
l'opus l'arrivée des accords
cette cour la mécanisation
non mais moi c'est moi je jamais fumé
durée de la vie c'est ça comme ça voire
serra non mais je suis honnête j'ai
jamais fumé des joints par contre je
suis d'accord parce qu'en fait ça change
rien c'est vrai que c'est pas plus grave
qu autre chose et que le fait
d'interdire ces idiots ça change rien
contre moi je ne suis pas pour que les
gens fument des joints mais je m'en
fiche moi je propose avant 9 heures avec
laurent gerra - d'après le clan non il
est sain c'est la peur et la corse est
pas une insulte et axa veut rien dire
oui enfin ça veut dire à réagir à des
shows vous a déjà emmené chez ses
parents à bourg-en-bresse voit alors
c'est bien passé merci jack